what is going on there reject nation
greg here today i am finally about to
watch a movie that every one of my
friends circle
everyone even strangers who come up to
me or like hey man big fan of the real
rejects everyone makes me feel left out
for not having seen this movie
everything everywhere all at once this
is getting unanimous praise all around
and i grew up on michelle yo film so i'm
already very much inclined to see this
film yet i've never even seen a trailer
for it so i know nothing about it and it
has something to do with multiverses i
know it starts michelle yo i know it
features my boys from marshall club
brian and andy i'm very much excited to
see what they do in this film because if
you haven't seen their channel marshall
club please go check it out it is
awesome stuff even did an interview with
andy here on the channel that was like
an hour long but yeah i mean the
conversation here's how the real
conversation goes almost with everyone i
talk to someone is telling me why they
don't like doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and then it's
instantly followed by but but have you
seen everything everywhere all at once
if doctor strange did that oh man then
that would be a good movie then that's
literally the conversation all the time
but yeah guys this is just reaction
highlights full length watch alongs
where you sync up with the time code
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page we cover a
whole bunch of movies and shows over
there reaction highlights and
watch-alongs included at the same tier
if you guys can please go ahead and
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated helps designing the
algorithm and a comment while you're at
it and subscribe and click that
notification bell because we got a lot
in the pipeline right now i mean we got
koi's comic corner going you know we got
our regular shows and movies that we're
covering whatever trailers come out at
the same time i'm gearing up to start
releasing these videos with it for og
real rejects fans salamander sally who's
doing a marvel react series i mean she
hasn't seen most of the marvel movies so
a few of them are re-watched most of
them are a first time watching hoping to
start delivering those in july thank you
all for being here and thanks to the
prepper boys for helping us edit down
these highlights you've been a major
part of the channel especially in the
last year let's see what all the hype is
about
[Music]
that's a cool shot
it's a good match good
whoa
wicked it starts off on america she's
gonna be going through a multiverse
looking at reflections of herself
but
yeah but
asian household you're always going to
look for your parents approval and never
get it
a divorce
hi evelyn mrs wong hey mom
[Laughter]
becky becky says she
you know me i always
he make
chinese just one word tough so easy and
the way you two are dressed i'm sure i'm
not the only one calling him he i mean
her
[Laughter]
you and becky can stay here and decorate
whoa i know you haven't always liked
becky okay i like becky she is very nice
you are very lucky
haha
[Laughter]
[Music]
this
embrace the gayness
joy wait please
i have something to say to you what
you have to try and eat healthier oh no
that's all we do
oh no
god damn it
this movie surprisingly feels very
personal for me already
goddamn
[Music]
oh cool many chapters
i could tell i'm going to be crying
already it's already like touching me on
like so many personal sciences
you may be in grave danger what the [__]
[Laughter]
what hey yo
why you don't know all these apps on my
book
[Music]
what the hell
follow these instructions don't even
talk to me about this because i won't
remember
talk to you soon
ah
okay everyone was right this movie is
amazing on every for every level it's
[Laughter]
amazing oh i am so digging this i was
just hoping
that you could explain this i thought
that was jamie lee curtis wait is that
jay really cursed
how is a laundromat owner
a karaoke machine could constitute a
business expense i am a
singer evelyn sing a song for her
no no please
[Laughter]
what what is watsu it's a water massage
[Music]
what is about to happen
this music is phenomenal
[Music]
they don't know you and i are in this
universe yet i'm here because we need
your help
very busy today
i've spent years searching for the one
who might be able to imagine this great
evil with an even greater good and bring
back balance all those years of
searching have brought me here i know
it's a lot to take in right now
mrs wang hello
god i'm loving this this is so good this
is so [__] good
i am going to bring that sorry everyone
unless you can help me with my taxes
[Laughter]
she reminds me of my mom so much man
it's not my mom would handle
this every disappointment has led you
here
to this moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
this movie just swells you so much
emotion holy [__] oh god this is just a
photo universe we're using for
communication
if you want to redo you're going to
resubmit
i will be in contact soon
i think my other husband's
[Laughter]
you will have until you've got the
office tonight to bring everything in 6
p.m oh tomorrow
[Laughter]
i have no idea how far i'm into this
movie but i already think this should
win best pitcher and best director and
best lead performance
this is amazing
i'm not ready to fight maybe we don't
have a choice
gosh
[Music]
sweet shoes to what
i'll get you out of this stop coming
here
oh buddy
that one right there the chinese lady no
it's all he's wrong
okay i need you to get on the ground
with your hands behind your head damn
brad's an actual character
[Music]
oh the wise oh [__] oh [__]
cool
oh man
[Music]
you know marshall club was very much
involved in this choreography because
brighter andy
nice that's a weight to it
[Music]
[__]
yikes
i like watching classic jackie chan
cinema baby just with a lot more kinetic
editing and directing what fragile
branches your self-worth rests
[Music]
oh my god what the hell
i love the filmmaking choice to keep
changing dimensions of the screen from
like four by three to widescreen
as you're hopping through dimensions
that's so cool it's called first jumping
i need you to learn how to do it right
now
right now
[Music]
it may be your only chance of getting
out of your life wicked you've been
feeling it too and you stay up at night
wondering to yourself how can we get
back
but that begins with finding the one who
can stand up to jobu's perverse shot of
chaos
and you think it's me yeah this is a
better multiverse movie than orchestra
already i feel it yeah
calculating roots
okay some paper cuts four of them one
between each finger
paper that's only happening
it's impossible
there we go one
[Music]
three all right come on come on come on
stay with me
that is not bearable you can feel it
she's got a rug no she can jump
somewhere she can fight she's not ready
jump like that would fry most people
she's not most people she's not most
people she's god dave evelyn you
developed an algorithm that calculates
which statistically improper action will
place you in the universe on the edge of
your local cluster which then slingshots
you to the desired universe kung fu
universe
the next best pass i'll break your own
arm or take a nap you're not sleepy are
you
i love you
wait no
she's in a local divergent universe no
no she's gone home
to finish the taxes
[Laughter]
i need to go
i need to find the right evelyn
and this one no it's not the one
is [__] amazing
i love you
take a nap
wow turn down for what
[Music]
i love you i love you
yes
[Music]
oh this is [__] great
oh god damn
i already want to re-watch this movie
[Music]
it was beautiful
that's painful
what if i want to go back to the other
universe
shut it down shut it down you hear me
come back okay okay okay
i'm
a mind experiences every world
every possibility commanding the
infinite knowledge and power of the
multiverse
[Music]
ah she still meets him
goddamn great ass movies y'all
recommending me making me cry my eyes
out all goddamn
[Music]
jump to another combat universe i feel
yourself it's always
this movie is so overwhelming
[Music]
joy
why do you look so stupid
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
oh my god
[Music]
jesus
what did you jump
she's off the damn map
[Music]
holy god
it's crazy you're starting to get it
[Music]
where are you gonna go
oh that is disturbing oh that's so gross
whoever the daughter is she's amazing
i'm
i don't know who that actress is she's
incredible i've seen thousands of
evelyn's but never i ever like you
you have so many goals you never
finished
dreams you never followed
you're living you're worth you
what i cannot be the worst
what about the hot dog one no
most people only have a few significant
out in the life path so close to them
you're capable of anything
because you're so bad at everything
interesting
weakness is her strength joy why are you
here i have no [__] clue hey gentle
language
what the [__] are you doing
[Laughter]
wow she is distracted
wow it's only protocol it gives her one
less universe to access
oh god no there's no way but it's a
sacrifice that is necessary
to win the war okay
[Music]
you must do it no no no no way in hell
no
it's only a matter of time before you
become just like her
what the [__]
i cannot lose another loved one to the
darkness
don't worry
you won't
oh oh oh god i love how introspective
the
multiverse journey is
making the evelyn character your time is
up
find your jumping pads
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the most beautiful looking film
i've seen in a while man
[Music]
cool
oh yes
is he dead
see not dead go
[Laughter]
go show
what the [__] is she about to fight a
dog does my baby want to go for a walk
[Laughter]
you gotta be [__] me
cut out this drunken master inspiration
[__] chad
yes
god suspended say dream come true for
this guy
what happened i think they lost their
stomach power
i'm you know the jumping pad
[Music]
oh god
[Laughter]
oh
[__]
[Music]
oh
damn andy and brian the same scene
fantastic
[Applause]
oh it's hanging out of him
[__] yeah
[Music]
oh [__]
yes
wow what a shot
i'm sorry evelyn
[Music]
crank like quality do this
awesome
[Music]
incredible stop working this
come on
i love this guy
who is the husband and and daughter man
i'm grateful
that chance was kind enough to let us
have these last few moments together
oh man
ah you still can't see what's happening
no i see
more clearly than ever before
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
um
oh she's multiverse happened it's quite
significantly
[Music]
hot dog hands
that is really disturbing can you go
help my dad with the party
go go
thanks babe
guys so
so immersive
you can see
how everything
is just a random rearrangement of
particles
i have no idea what you are talking
about but i can
crazy
but you see
how everything
[Music]
gets washed away in a sea of every other
possibility
yup i'm glad i did not watch this before
doctor
stretch i would have definitely compared
the [__] out of it
oh god
hit me
the mirror
[Laughter]
i know
the joy and the pain of having you as my
mother i would only do the right thing
for her
right is a tiny box invented by people
who are afraid
i wasn't looking for you so i could kill
you i was just looking for someone who
could see what i see
feel
what i feel mrs wang
i need to not even show up
we're just going around in circles
laundry attacks
no more running excuse me we're the
owners gotta let it all go you have left
me no option but to authorize the
seizure of your personal and your
business assets
no she has entered [__] mode
there's only a few specs of time where
anything actually makes any sense
[Music]
tear it all down man
oh my god
i gotta see any rockstars easter egg
breakdown video that
whoa this movie's so hypnotic
[Music]
[Laughter]
would have thought this scene could be
so tender
i wanted to see if i went in could i
finally escape
like actually die
my silly husband was
probably making things worse
ignore it
okay you can let it go
what
that was actually
fine
how
i don't know
i just talked to her
i know you're all fighting because
you're scared and confused
[Music]
you can still turn around and avoid all
this
[Music]
huh
[__]
please [__] destroy me
[Music]
so much
oh [__]
feeling a good thing
they got your hopes up so i'm here to
save you some time
god i feel like i needed this movie
[Music]
ah
what did my silly husband say to you
he told me about your situation
god what the [__] is this movie
to how'd they make this mess incredible
you're not i'm you're not unlovable
what are you talking about
there is always something to love
even in a stupid stupid universe
[Music]
oh third eye
[Laughter]
evelyn
[Music]
fight with love pitchmen or the nervous
system
with a little bit of help we should be
seeing things that are nice and straight
thank you
good thing you're not alive
[Music]
but she turned out to be stubborn
aimless
a mess
just like a mother
and gay just like her in that hot dog
universe
[Music]
oh [__]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wow
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm tired
i don't want to hurt anymore and for
some reason when i'm with you it just
it just hurts the both of us
yeah
just let me go
okay
just let her be her own person trust her
no matter what
i still want to be here with you
i will always
always
want to be here with you
so what
i'm just gonna ignore everything else
guys i've all cried out goddamn
no boy it's so moving
you might not go somewhere where you're
where your daughter is more than just
this
here all we get
are a few
specks of time where any of this
actually makes any sense
then i will cherish
these few specks of time
yes
push the button
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did he say
[Music]
ah
we can do whatever we want
nothing matters i need bread
nothing
does anyone have any orange slices
i do think
things are better this is this is a an
improvement and that has to do with this
guest disease
evelyn did you hear me
sorry
what did you say
well somebody scrolls out
[Music]
the [__] russo brothers produced this
[__]
no i have not seen swiss army man
god damn that was
uh
i need to
stand
i need to stand i'll be right back with
you guys just stand around this room for
a sec
oh boy
i keep an ice pack on my lower back when
i
film oh
[Music]
boy holy [__] that was
a [__] experience right there
i've never
oh
christ regup recoup
i love how i put this mic up here and i
barely [__] talked all i did was just
get lost in this film
so transport
for sure at the beginning i was like it
looks like jamie lee curtis and it is jp
leakers
and i never clarify that i realized for
sure it was jamie lee curtis so i bet
there's a lot of comments of people
saying
craig it is jamie lee curtis uh
how to just
that's what the credits roll that is um
uh so overwhelming i was not expecting
that i didn't know what to expect i
thought i was going to get like a cool
it was that it was like a cool
experimental multiverse movie
you know and hearing the uh
just
run into the mic and hearing that the
you know like brian and annie were in
this movie
like okay there's a spot to be like a
fight scene i don't i had no idea i i
don't think anything could have prepared
me for this uh that
the amount of hype i have heard about
this film
the amount of insane hype did not do it
justice for me this was so wow that was
um
it's like i need to rewatch this i need
to go again i need to watch this in the
theaters i'm glad i got to experience
this the first time with
all of you i was not expecting if i
fight choreography bye bye them oh sweet
they did the fight choreography [__]
yeah i didn't know that glad i'm
sticking around for the credits
uh yeah i
need to process this for a little bit
i guess the one thing i would say while
the credits are rolling is this is the
kind of movies
you know like i'm not going to try to
sit here and try to
sound all like
intellectualize everything because
there's there's so much
here on every front from the from the
writing directing the set pieces the
performances
the themes and there's there's so much
and it moves at such a incredible pace
this really could have been a movie that
could have been frustrating and annoying
and yet
for me it wasn't it's just one of those
movies you feel that's that's what it is
you just you just feel
this experience don't overthink it you
know you just go with it you either go
with it or you don't i've never
experienced a movie like this ever this
is originality at its finest
and i do not blame anyone
who saw this
first and then watch multiverse madness
and then as i've heard that so many
times
do not believe i'm sure many of you have
to people that i have talked to who who
usually tell me their opinion about this
movie and i don't dive into it because
like now i just want to watch like i
don't get details other than the fact
that i hear people love it
but yeah when they compare this yeah i
imagine i would like multiverse of
madness less if i watch this within the
same week
of going now there's so much more they
could have done though because this just
gets you in every way it feel like i
just fluctuated between it being
exciting and it being like emotional
you know this was a great character
study and they utilized the multiverse
traveling for this character evelyn to
truly grow and discover things about
herself learn things about herself and
to have a story that's so massive and so
expansive and so wild and experimental
and trippy but to really just have it be
about like the at its core it's such a
simple story at its core you know it's a
story about
uh
a mother and a daughter essentially it's
about evelyn and this
the pain she's held on to and how it's
affected
her appreciation
and her her treatment towards her loved
ones and then
living in the shadow of her dad like at
its heart there's just a
damn good asian family drama
and then if really but then the backdrop
is this crazy multiverse world
of you know because it's like resentment
begetting resentment generational trauma
familial trauma i mean if you go to my
23andme tests and all kinds of asian and
then
italian european stuff
but growing up my identity association
was always italian there's no post
credits
my identification was always uh italian
filipino but i i a hundred percent like
primarily grew up with my filipino aside
seeing a lot of the family stuff and
especially
my mom my mama always talking to me
about taxes
all the time for years about taxes
especially when i started living off a
youtube channel always about taxes yeah
there's like definite things that i've
not just in my own you know you know
immediate family but being surrounded by
a lot of uh asian american friends who
and being what being privy to their
families
and then seeing
as some of uh you know a lot of that is
very much reflected here but they just
told such a beautiful story
at the end of it all it's hard it's just
such a it's such a beautiful story
conquering through the power of love
that's why i think it's so great because
as as wild as it is and as
as heady as it is it's really so simple
and it's amazing they managed to make a
movie that's so easy to
it's so easy for audiences to to to
grasp on to it's a lot to keep up with
but i'm never but and it's overwhelming
in in the ways that feel right you know
because you're just getting you kind of
got to get swept up in the tone and the
music and its style and the surprising
relationship with with the irs auditing
lady jb lee curtis and
how that forms and learning to put your
walls down and and just be learning to
be vulnerable like this brought out
something so vulnerable out of me uh a
like a movie about learning to be more
in tune with how you feel underneath and
just just to be honest with yourself and
be honest with the ones you love but and
but also to appreciate it like such
such great simple values you know told
in this like poetic way and and i i
loved how this evelyn character i guess
i was gonna to go out to the kitchen and
grab a piece of bread but i guess i'm
talking right now i i love how this
evelyn character as she explores the
universe is every version of evelyn let
me adjust this a little bit yeah
yeah right up in my [__] mouth it's
really really
so much of what she was experimenting
with so much of what she was seeing with
like the other versions of herself were
these people who were you know kind of
dead set and and sort of like had a
calling you know not every one of them
but but most of them seem to have like a
specific kind of purpose and a calling
and then with evelyn being the one
who just
kind of rejects
the plans and and rejects her true
desires conforms and doesn't actually
like in every universe you start to see
reflections of who she is like i thought
that was really cool like even in her
blossoming singing career her dad is
still hovering over her shoulder and
watching her our evelyn that we're
watching you know because she's the one
who ultimately
kind of failed at so many things and not
going after what she really wanted to be
and she's able to sort of absorb and
become
everything
and you know because she kind of feels
like she's nothing she can become
everything she's like the wild card i
thought that was so beautiful because so
much of this inspirational message is
about learning to
let go and
yeah like in in talking on on a universe
on a in a universe level my fiance is
obsessed with uh like astronomy and all
that space trust you even tried getting
me to listen to this audio the other day
but my mind was caught up in all its own
and all the things that i had to get
done that day and she wanted me to
listen to this you know what the speech
was but they're really popular like one
of the most famous speeches about space
the bits i was able to eventually get
lost into is like yeah you really do
realize that if we get caught up in so
much [__] on earth but really you know
our time is so finite it's so limited
here yet we get so caught up in
circumstances and the immediacy and
everything about you know society and
satisfying this satisfying that yeah
you're just a tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny
tiny fraction
of the universe not even a fraction like
the the universe is so massive and
expansive that we might as well just
kind of try to enjoy our lives and as
easy as said as easy as it is to say
that um i do not live by that i just i
don't i don't live by that i get caught
up when this is done rolling i'm gonna
be caught up probably most likely and
you know and having to like import this
footage and get everything something to
sing and get to work on editing like it
just could immediately
be caught up in that
instead of just like let me slow down a
little bit and try to appreciate it and
to tell someone i love them but maybe
i'll take that lesson with me because
this was one of the most inspiring
things i've ever seen you know as
someone who loves to write myself is one
of those films that it feels like kind
of daunting in in a sense of god will i
ever i could i don't know if i could
ever write something this this great
this grandiose because this was
beautifully written everything was just
so [__] thought out like everything
is so thought out and they do not have
the marvel budget like i get it i don't
want to make this video just comparing
this to multiverse of madness but i get
it i get why people do it because yeah
there's a lot of very similar plot
driven thing even the [__] villain of
the movie is a scorned scorned woman the
nuances they bring and the performances
are so
powerful so
effective everyone michelle yo
yo she killed it she was amazing
she was everything everywhere all i was
she was amazing holy [__] balls man it
wasn't catching the the the names of the
actors uh uh but you know the ones play
joy and and wayman uh
wow holy crap like
the you know especially the guy plays
waymon the the the the different
portrayals he had to do like going in
and out of the quirkiness the strong
determined fighter of a husband who's
inspired by his universe's evelyn alpha
version right the layman who looks like
he is from a certain perspective looks
weak but when you realize he's not
really weak that love and kindness is
his strength and learning to accept that
and be supportive you know i thought it
was such like everyone did such a
beautiful job and that the character joy
i forget the the villain name
but her performance too they ask a lot
of everyone here because everyone here
does not have to just do emotionality
stuff but everyone has to be so physical
and i just mean in terms of like the
fight scenes but even like the littlest
quirks they have to be so physical about
when switching in and out of these
characters you know whatever they're
being affected by multiverse wives
everyone's required to do so much in
this film and they all deliver the dad
another great one like everyone brought
so much depth and humanity and so much
more but like this this is across the
board for everyone here they and they
all brought something deeper underneath
the eyes if that make i feel like that
makes sense yeah they all brought
something deeper underneath the eyes and
i'm like how do you direct a film like
my mind is spinning right now because
i'm like how do you direct a
a film like this how do you get the
actors on board how are the actors
absorbing this while they're making this
movie the set photography the the
production design was it was uh
was was wild and like there's things in
here where i'm like god i gotta see a
youtube video that that goes frame by
frame on all this all those crazy like
match cuts between all the universe i
got i got to see how that all works um
it's like the kind of movie you want to
like study and and and revisit because
yeah this was transportive you know it's
really
it's you know as part of the the weird
part about doing the reaction stuff you
have to make commentary especially
because
this is that's how you make it more fair
use and of course it has to be cut up
but at the same time you know like the
the main goal when you're when we're
covering like a show or movie is just to
do our best to get lost in it but i'm
always like kind of aware there's a
camera there and this was the probably
the first movie i've seen
ever with on the maybe i don't know
actually it certainly feels that way
though i've never been that
like
lost in a in a film before with a
[__] camera pointed at me that really
put me in a a whole new level you know
like i forget about the lights and and
all that comment
because yeah i was just lost in it when
i bring people on here i'm like yeah the
main thing is you know uh just
experience it and just you know whatever
you're feeling internally let it out you
know whether that be through commentary
in between characters or talking or when
uh or just to show it with your actual
emotions that was happening so
subconsciously without me like aware of
it at all like this was breaking me and
in internally sure there's some [__] in
with me with identifying like because my
with with like
any time i see old asian people i think
of my family bottom line that's just
where my mind goes i think of my family
there's parts of michellio's character
that definitely reminded me of my mom
it's not a one-on-one comparison but
there were enough shades of it that
would remind me of my mom beyond that i
don't even think if that was the case i
i still would have been just as moved
you know i was i was insanely moved by
this one i i wasn't expecting to walk
into a movie that i was
i was going to be that emotional about
because it's also a love story at the
end of the day it's like it's this love
story it's a it's it's a it's a it's
just a story about relation like how did
they do that how they how they make
something that was just so goddamn
personal and about relationships that
was so intimate but
bigger
than
marvel's multiverse madness like how do
they do that and it's also like a film
making movie you know working with the
the four by three dimensions when it's
just like
this frame black borders on the side and
then going from widescreen to kind of be
like we're in action movie mode and then
knowing when to go full screen like it
looks like they experimented with
different lenses throughout this yeah
the amount of insane creativity on board
without making you lose sight of the
heart at the end of the day
end of the day heart that was wild
i've
never experienced something like this
before i don't see any movie getting
better than this this year i want to
watch it in the theaters that might be
one of the greatest things i've ever
seen
[Laughter]
wow
wow it's ethereal
the sweeping
it was
adventurous ambitious
creative innovative
uh i think michelle yo
should definitely be considered for
i think all of them should be considered
for oscar consideration even though i do
think oscars are [__]
i think it's just gonna be a big reality
show i do think in terms of performances
i know it's so early on in the year but
god damn please do not forget about
michellio's work here because she was
phenomenal like wow like there's so many
different genres
spliced into here god might just flash
like how the [__] like the way they
managed to make like craziness and then
go to like the talking like the rocks
and make the rocks feel like such a
tender sweet moment damn this was a
movie that creates passion it's like the
simple story just like i don't want to
live in my parents shadows anymore
that's what it all really comes down to
and if i don't do that live under that
rule and and forgive and accept thyself
you can have a more loving grateful life
like this is really what it's all about
this is kind of moving i want to like
call people up and talk to them about
whoever seen it because no no one i'm
glad everyone did not it's kind of
a big thing
something about me is a lot of times if
i go to screen screenings or premieres i
don't really talk to people too much
afterwards because a lot of times it
feels like it's a competition for who
can give out their their review to me
like right away you know that's what
everyone wants to do it's like they
they'll ask what'd you think of the
movie but 99 of the people who are
asking that are just waiting to give
their review of the film so i just kind
of give like one or two sentences and
with this i'm glad that everyone i know
did not review the movie for me they
just kind of gave me like a quick
opinion but just heavily encouraged me
to see it i gotta watch it again i gotta
watch it again and pick up all the
details because this was
magnificent and beautiful i thought it
might have been overhyped i thought it
was actually at the end of it i thought
it was underhyped and that was
that was a revelation of an experience
holy [__]
why would i watch anything else after
this movie
thank you guys
uh
well i'll talk with you all soon
thank you for being here subscribe click
that bell and
thank you to the prepper boys helping me
edit down these highlights especially
check us out on patreon bye
[Music]